mo what's going on brother uh well i'm
having a problem
just with me being muslim
and you know being outwardly muslim you
know as in just my appearance where i
wear a koopa
at like uh as a recently like i've been
having problems where i pray
outside for lunch or something and
people drive by and throw bottles at me
and call me you know saying saying
derogative words you know like
saying this yeah i know it's i'm 21 and
i've been dealing with it my whole life
and it hasn't been this bad ever since i
moved
to south carolina 10 months ago and i
just don't know if i even want to
deal with it anymore bro i'm sorry man
i was like i don't man i hate that for
you
i hate that for you don't deserve that
man i'm glad you're a part of our
communities i hate that you're
experiencing that
what are you doing in south carolina
what are you there for i'm going to
school
going to school um is this happening on
campus or is this just a part of making
your way through that community
mostly out of campus when i go to work
okay
man
man you broke my heart mo and i'm not
the one hurting here so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna take your story from you
but
man i i hate that you're experiencing
that i hate that people are so
ignorant and stupid and repulsive that
they would treat another person like
that
especially someone who's simply trying
to express their faith
in a gentle way i hate it um
so i wish i could tell you that i
haven't worked at college campuses where
i've had to have this conversation with
students in your situation before but i
have
um at the end of the day the most you
can do is take care of you
right and if somebody's throwing bottles
at you obviously that's a crime
right that's a criminal act and i hope
that you're in a situation where you're
safe enough to get the authorities
involved in that
um but i know that's easier said than
done right and
yeah it's kind of like it happened like
when i was praying so i
couldn't even get my eyes on them i mean
yeah
so here's the deal you got to find
people you can be safe with
okay you got if you're not safe or if
your professors are out of bounds i'm
going to tell you something crazy
um you've got it you've got to be safe
or you can't do the things to learn
right you've got to be safe or you can't
fully express your faith
if you've got to be safe or you can't
connect with other people where you're
going to find
your future spouse where you're going to
find your community right
and over time when those things happen
in a concentrated area like that you say
it
has never happened like this right
people have run their mouth
my whole life i've lived in new york i
mean virginia and it's
i've never experienced this amount of
blatant racism
strictly to my face man
ever so hey
what do you want to be when you grow up
ma'am uh
engineer a civil engineer oh you mean
you want to help bridges and roads so
people can get to work and go see their
kids
yes sir what a jerk dude what a jerk moe
unbelievable why did you say that why
did you give me a job that
is going to be dedicated to service of
others you know why because you're a
good person brother
god that pisses me off man exactly
i can go real quick from heartbroken to
real pissed off fast and i don't get mad
very often man but you got my heart all
riled up
listen um yeah i mean even my best
friends who are christians
even they try to help me out here and
then but it's like when i get caught off
guard
by myself it's it's a lot you know and i
i try my best not to fight
or get angry or aggressive but it just
when it keeps on happening it's like if
there's a test or
i don't know i want you to protect your
heart man
i want you to protect your heart and if
that means
leaving school leaving that area and
going to some place that's going to
honor you and your faith and that might
be what you have to do
um this is going to sound crazy i've
been in a place that
was not appreciative of my faith and i
ended up taking out and going somewhere
else
okay um yeah i also don't want to
encourage people who are
i don't want to encourage that type of
blatant racism man and
so it's easy for me as a privileged guy
to sit on the outside and say
here's what you should be doing you know
what i mean um yeah
at the end of the day you've got to be
safe and you've got to find people who
care and love for you and your heart and
your heart of service
you know what i mean you deserve that
and i
hate the fact that people in our
community
and my region of the country are
treating you like that
right what i don't want you to do and
this is gonna sound trivial and i've got
no man
what i'm gonna tell you is gonna sound
so trite and so silly and so privileged
and so i'm gonna apologize on the front
end but i mean it from the bottom of my
heart
i don't want the ignorance and idiocy
and stupidity of a few
to sour your heart to change your spirit
and to begin to shift your default
setting to
not one of love and peace and compassion
and service to other people but one of
anger and hate okay yeah
and i want you to know i'm gonna do what
i can as a part of
my community to speak loudly and boldly
from the inside out on how we treat
people who are different than us and
look different than us and pray
different than us
and also i want you to make sure you
protect and take care of your heart and
soul
yes sir right
yeah you deserve better than this i i
need you
making good roads for that my kids are
going to drive on okay
i need you dedicating your life to
fixing all the buildings that are
falling i don't know whatever civil
engineers do but i just know that my
kids need you
okay i need you yes sir okay yes sir
you got it yes sir thank you
so whatever you got to do to make sure
you got people you can be safe with
people that will rally around you maybe
it's getting a group of
call your christian friends on the
carpet say i'm going out to pray
and i want you all to pray with me it's
gonna look different
yeah come with me right
you know um it may be it may be she
gotta leave man and i hate that i hate
that for you i hate that for your school
community
and hate that yeah me and my mom been
talking about it she wants me to leave
but i just i just i
i kind of want to just try to finish the
semester out but i got you i got you
yeah
that's brave but take care of your heart
okay all right
talk to the people at your school too
let them know what you're going through
make sure you are meeting with people
on campus and let them know what you're
experiencing sometimes college campuses
i've i've had myself
i've been called on the carpet on this
um
college folks have partnerships with
local police they have partnerships with
local
churches local schools and um
sometimes it's the school's
responsibility to get involved in making
sure that there's a safe educational
environment for their students
right all right and um i love you man
i'm glad that you're out there going to
school to
serve other people and um
keep yourself safe okay if that means
you gotta go you gotta go
cali stop everybody
quit ignorant
stupid morons throwing bottles at people
man
let people pray in peace for crying out
loud let people dress how they want to
dress for crying out loud
it's freaking ridiculous man stop
stop and if you see that nonsense in
your friend group
cut it out cut it out
if you hear somebody in your friend
group talking like an idiot cut it out
tell them to stop none of this crap
stops
until people in the majority say enough
we're done with it we're going to let
people be not we're not only going to
let people be
we're going to love people because i
need more civil engineers you know what
they're doing
i need more everybody i don't care what
their outcome is that made me sound like
i just want to love people because of
what they're going to
do for us no i love people because
they're worth loving
drives me crazy